ya platicamos de la gravedad ya
platicamos del electrostática así que es
momento de hablar de otras de las
fuerzas fundamentales en la física y
creo que es la segunda más común es el
magnetismo me voy a poner aquí más de
magnetismo vale magnetismo esta palabra
viene de magnesia le voy a poner aquí
magnesio magnesia y magnesio fue una de
las principales localidades fue fue una
provincia acerca de de grecia en donde
se empezaron a encontrar estas piedras
misteriosas que tenían como una fuerza
que les permitía atraer otras piedras
misteriosas o bien objetos metálicos
como el hierro objetos ferrosos después
pues surgió por ahí la palabra imán imán
que viene del francés hay mante imán
vale pero ahorita no me quiero meter
mucho en lingüísticas más bien me quiero
meter aquí a la física del magnetismo
bueno creo que todos tenemos una idea
pues al menos un poco vaga de qué se
trata esto del magnetismo hemos jugado
con imanes y con brújulas
lo que realmente es el magnetismo en el
fondo es algo muy muy profundo aunque si
podemos manejarlo y entenderlo
matemáticamente por ejemplo sabemos que
la fuerza electrostática y la magnética
son la misma pero vista desde distintos
marcos de referencia sé que eso suena un
poco complicado de hecho en la física
newtoniana clásica pues si se tratan
como dos cosas distintas pero bueno ya
me estoy yendo por la tangente más bien
así como estamos acostumbrados no sé
digamos a la gravedad pues también
estamos acostumbrados al magnetismo en
el sentido de que hemos jugado dos con
estas dos fuerzas verdad pero así como
la gravedad es una fuerza muy misteriosa
cuando nos ponemos a pensar en ella
también el magnetismo bueno con esto
dicho vamos a trabajar tantito para ver
cómo se puede lidiar con los imanes y
con las cargas y con los polos vale
entonces para esto déjame dibujar un
imán
no voy a poner por acá está el imán y lo
voy a dividir en dos
entonces este el imán dividido en dos
los imanes tienen dos polos el polo
norte y un polo sur ahora estos nombres
de polo norte y polo sur están nombrados
simplemente por convención como se le
ocurrió a las personas ponerles así pues
por ejemplo cuando y mandaban una aguja
y la ponían sobre un corcho y hacían
flotar el corcho sobre agua de modo que
no hubiera fricción la aguja apuntaba
hacia una dirección y esa dirección
justo estaba cerca del norte geográfico
de la tierra va de modo similar el otro
lado de la aguja apuntaba hacia el sur
geográfico de la tierra y entonces el el
extremo que apuntaba hacia el norte
geográfico le ponían el norte del imán y
el que apuntaba hacia el sur le ponía en
el sur de del imán vale pasa lo mismo
con los imanes si no tienen fricción no
tiene por qué ser una aguja si un imán
no tiene nada de fricción su lado norte
va a apuntar cerca del norte geográfico
de la tierra y su lado sur cerca del sur
geográfico ahora te hace estar
preguntando por qué digo cerca
no dijo exactamente hacia el norte
geográfico y para eso déjame dibujar no
voy a poner un poco más para acá voy a
dibujar a la tierra va entonces esa de
ahí es la tierra e imaginemos que en
este lado está el polo norte el polo
norte polo norte geográfico y de este
lado está el polo sur polo sur
pues resulta que las brújulas y las
agujas imantadas y los imanes no apuntan
exactamente al polo norte apuntan hacia
un punto que está tantito desviado
tantito desviado que es el norte el
norte magnético vale y eso se debe pues
a distintos fluidos y a varios fenómenos
pero no es el mismo que el polo norte
geográfico de manera similar el polo sur
el polo sur magnético está como por acá
tantito desviado del polo sur y es
opuesto al polo norte y el polo norte
magnético está más o menos por canadá el
polo sur el polo sur magnético no sé muy
bien donde esté pero vaya el punto es el
punto que quería contar es que este eje
el de el eje de de los polos magnéticos
no es el mismo que el eje de los polos
geográficos
una aguja apunta hacia el norte
magnético hacia el norte magnético de la
tierra pero ojo qué sucede cuando
pensamos a la tierra como un imán
cuando pensamos a la tierra como un imán
este lado que es el del norte magnético
no es el polo norte de la tierra como un
imán sino es el polo sur y de modo
similar el de acá es el polo norte va
entonces bueno esto aquí puede ser un
poco confuso puedes leer un poco más en
wikipedia nada más quería compartir te
lo por si alguna vez lo ves así pero no
te preocupes en general cuando la gente
se refiere al norte magnético se refiere
pues al punto donde apuntan las agujas
que está cerca del norte geográfico y de
modo similar el sur magnético es el que
está cerca del sur geográfico pero por
qué sucede esto porque sucede que este
es el sur de la tierra con miman y este
es el norte de la tierra como imán para
pues el magnetismo justo como pasaba en
electrostática esta es una de las cosas
que tienen en común
ahorita paso a las diferencias de hecho
te voy a dar una diferencia fundamental
pero el magnetismo justo como en
electrostática resulta que los polos
opuestos se atraen
y los polos iguales se repelen entonces
aquí como el imán o la aguja está
apuntando hacia este punto de acá pues
eso quiere decir que este que este polo
de la tierra es el opuesto a este polo
del imán como este es el polo norte por
apuntar hacia el norte magnético pues
resulta que está siendo atraído hacia
este que es el polo sur de la tierra con
mi mano y lo mismo pasa por acá lo mismo
pasa por acá vale entonces el polo sur
del imán es atraído al polo norte de la
tierra que está del lado del sur
magnético uf eso está súper confuso
verdad bueno ya vamos a dejar de hablar
de la tierra porque eso realmente puede
traer muchas confusiones vamos a algo un
poco consistente que van a ser puras
barras entonces voy a poner acá otros
dos imanes voy a poner por acá si de
este lado de este lado voy a poner otros
dos imanes ahí tenemos un imán y ahí
tenemos otro imán
déjame poner
y su división para marcar los polos
ok entonces ahí tenemos dos imanes en sí
este es el polo sur y este es el polo
norte para que los imanes se atraigan
para que estiman que atraiga a este otro
imán necesitamos que este sea el polo
sur y que este sea el pueblo norte a lo
mejor has jugado con imanes y te has
dado cuenta que si volteas este imán
ahora se repelen verdad entonces los
polos opuestos se repele vamos a otra
noción vamos a la noción de un campo
magnético y esto de campo magnético es
como todos los campos son algunos
vectores aquí alrededor del imán que
afectan de alguna forma a las cosas que
entran en el campo va pero sabes que
antes de eso antes de platicar de los
campos magnéticos déjame darte una
diferencia fundamental entre magnetismo
y electrostática el magnetismo las cosas
siempre vienen en dipolos o sea tienen
un polo norte y tienen un polo sur van
siempre vienen en dos polos ahora en
electrostática tenemos una idea similar
que es lo de las cargas hay cargas
positivas y hay cargas negativas
pero acá en electrostática puede pasar
que nada más tengamos un protón puede
ser que ahí esté el protón solito es el
protón tiene su campo su campo
electrostático y está pues ejerciendo
cierta fuerza sobre las cosas que se
acercan a él no hay problema puede
existir por si mismo y también los
electrones pueden existir por sí mismos
pueden existir monopolos pero acá el
magnetismo no el magnetismo todos son
dipolos de hecho si estiman lo cortamos
a la mitad si estiman lo cortamos déjame
cortar un poco más así que se vea que
está cortado
si lo cortamos a la mitad resulta que
así después milagrosamente uno de los
lados bueno cada uno de los lados tiene
su polo sur y su polo norte entonces
aquí te quedaría sur norte sur norte va
ahora teóricamente puede que sí exista
un monopolo magnético pero nosotros los
humanos no lo hemos observado en la
naturaleza de hecho si seguimos cortando
y cortando estos imanes hasta llegar a
un electrón ese electrón también es un
dipolo magnético y bueno no no es mucha
casualidad porque de hecho el campo
magnético de un imán está generado justo
por el espín de un electrón va cuando
hablamos de espín de electrones nos
imaginamos cómo esta bolita verdad que
está girando pero es un poco más
complicado que eso verdad porque los
electrones tienen tan poquita masa que
no sabemos si esa energía o masa y luego
pensar en energía girando es como muy
difícil en fin estas cosas empiezan a
poner metafísicas y es muy difícil
obtener la intuición es mejor ver cómo
se relacionan con las cosas
microscópicas va entonces resulta que
que el campo magnético que está en el
imán está generado justo por el spin de
los electrones y por como giran
alrededor de los protones
espero no estarte espantando mucho van a
más te quiero dar algunas pequeñas ideas
de qué pasa aquí a nivel microscópico
otra cosa porque una barra podría estar
magnetizada o no porque una aguja a
veces apunta al norte y a veces no pues
tiene que ver con la organización de los
electrones si los electrones están muy
organizados entonces no hay magnetismo
porque sus spin se cancelan sí entonces
pues no no hay magnetismo pero si
alineamos los spins y también los ejes
de rotación entonces se carga la aguja y
eso es lo que sucede cuando pasamos un
imán por una aguja pero bueno ahorita ya
estoy pasando los 10 minutos espero
haberte dado pues más o menos una idea
de cómo funciona esto de los imanes por
dentro nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo
para pensar más acerca de los campos
magnéticos de los campos magnéticos y de
iu pues también para pensar en cuál es
el efecto de un campo magnético sobre
una carga en
movimiento